hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar breaking down barriers in
healthcare an urgency for the clinical
laboratory to move to the forefront of
patient care presented by David
Humphreys head of Health Policy and
clinical evidence practice ew healthcare
economists Washington DC USA
I am Alexis Krause of laberd's and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by laberd's and brought to you
by Abbott to learn more please visit
Abbott comm now let's get started before
you begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send well answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen I now present
today's speaker mr. David Humphries for
a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen David you may now
begin your presentation Thank You Alexis
for the introduction is certainly the
opportunity to present the results what
I think is a really timely and
interesting study certainly as all
aspects of healthcare
earned a scrutiny in a way that can
drive value in the future the agenda
today for the webinar is simply present
the results of the study that we've
conducted looking at the state of the
clinical laboratory today its face
within the healthcare ecosystem and what
it can be in the future
before I get into the results of the
research that we've done
I want to disclose that this research
program and webinars sponsored by Abbott
I have nothing to disclose and again
give a bit of background at eiu
healthcare it's part of the economists
group we certainly have the history of
looking at issues of Intel
since around the world we are the
analytical arm of that group covered all
markets and in the world the EIU health
care has a great set of capabilities
that look at the issues from different
perspective from a market from a policy
from an economic and from a clinical
perspective and value-based healthcare
has been one of those topics that we
have spent quite a bit of time in
analyzing with that said before we get
into the research results it's always
good to be a look at that the broader
contacts the forces that play in the
world the graph that you see in this
line is not an unknown story when we
understand and certainly aware of all
the pressures from a cost perspective
from a population health need and how
that is impacting and putting a lot of
pressure both from populations
individual patients and health systems
itself and within that context of
value-based healthcare movement is a
good and a positive step in the right
direction that generate better results
but it isn't simply a simple equation of
outcomes over cost there's nuance and
understanding what outcomes are defining
that cost perspective with that said the
EIU has developed a framework for
understanding and really developing what
value-based healthcare means from a
policy perspective and you'll see a
reference throughout the work that we
discussed in the laboratory needs its
place in this world from enable the
context perspective looking at issues
HTA existence on the collection of data
like cost state or patient registries
integrated care and established care
pathways and incentive systems moving
away from steve service to something
that is more directly tied to outcomes
itself and in our work that we've done
you see positive developments that are
happening in multiple markets around the
world if that's incentives for those in
Sweden to be able to feed into disease
registries or collection of cost data in
South Korea or even integrated care
policies that like those that are
developed in Colombia at the same time
the migration from legacy healthcare
systems to though really focus on the
comms
the value have a work-in-progress
migrating systems like EHRs so that
capture all the data and empower people
to make better decisions there's
certainly like I said a work in progress
and most markets in the world and that's
why our research seen the development of
value-based principles is really a dead
Cynthia on stage but this gives this an
important framework as we look at the
issues particularly around the
laboratory and as we get into the
results of our study there were really
three key themes that we want to be able
to highlight and you'll see these themes
throughout the data analysis that will
present over the next 20 or 30 minutes
the first theme here is that it's very
clear that the laboratory plays a
secondary role within healthcare it
represents one percent of medical
literature when talking about values
health care 5% health care expenditures
and really a one-way flow of
communication between other stakeholders
at the same time our research and I
think it's a really exciting piece is
that there is a real opportunity
enabling environment to be able to put
the laboratory in a much greater
elevated position to have an impact on
the value equation and denry better
results for patients for systems and for
all those that participate in a
healthcare equal system that leaves the
third point mom while path of the future
is not defined it's very clear that
there are two different directions that
can be done one that really elevates the
laboratory it puts it into position but
it takes advantage of all the knowledge
and data and insights that can drive
more predictive better healthcare for
everybody involved or the system can
really impose changes and all those
involved and you'll see how that plays
out as we get towards all the action
later on now with this said we want to
give a little bit of context since was
the research that was conducted looking
at 14 markets advanced in emerging
economies around the world in doing more
than 5,000 surveys with healthcare
Chanel's lab directors executives within
hospitals talking to payers giving young
leaders to really understand what is the
state of the clinical laboratory within
that healthcare ecosystem today and
where can it be in the future
so the second the fourth question within
this lie are really very critical those
perceptions correct or incorrect really
drive behavior and the way the system
the flow of information occurs today and
the second level it's also very clear
through the research and was something
of very key points of what would a lab
2.0 a different level of involvement in
healthcare and leveraging all the
greater data insight to drive better
health care and you'll see those results
as we go through the rest of the webinar
now as we start to present those results
um it's important that we framed this
within the broader perspective and what
you see in the on the slide here are
those same four pillars of health care
another thing where the IU is developed
and we want to be able to put it within
the context of what is the opportunity
for the lab to impact improve upon that
value and what is the real reality that
perception of the labs a day from an
enabling environment perspective
education is certainly view to be
critical that healthcare professionals
more than half really desire just
receive that rate of the training but
the reality is less than 20% a lab
director surveyed provide that training
today we hear a lot about measuring
results by being seen markets like the
UK that demand for laboratory testing
continues to grow every single year the
same time do we feel confident on the
results 4.2 some issues that a high
percentage a decent percentage of those
tests are really necessary and drive
incremental value for the system
information from an integrative care
perspective again another the topic that
has been well spoken
Wow but it's a high percentage of
information that allows everybody that
participates in healthcare
decision-making found is not being
leveraged coming from the clinical
laboratory in this case in tes
appropriateness then all the right
decisions being made at the right time
lastly incentives is certainly a
critical issue and this is where you see
a difference in beliefs that exist that
executives of one hand really believe
the lab to be one of the critical
functions in delivering high quality
health health care Wow but at the same
time if there's no alignment on the KPIs
key performance indicators I mean
shooting for the same goals that's where
it generates imperfect system all of
this has locations implications that may
be very narrow the 200 billion in
wasteful spending in diagnosing
treatment that happens in the u.s. even
if a small portion of that is related to
the rolled laboratory place today that
reinvestment can have a great impact on
value if we reveal it said to be more
efficient in the future from a broader
perspective and look you need to be able
to predict healthcare needs that
populations have and sub-saharan Africa
by 2030 if the plan continues 50% of
patients go undiagnosed for diabetes
which represents an economic burden the
60 billion dollars but through the right
diagnosis now and in early interventions
you can change that trajectory and
really improve upon value in healthcare
let's dive a little bit deeper into the
issue of perceptions online of situation
is as it is for the Clinical Laboratory
healthcare now before we get into the
perceptions it's important to recognize
that part of this is financial that when
in the u.s. there may be upwards of 700
million less spent and services provided
the clinical laboratory or in the case
of Australia over a period of a decade
that expenditures and pathology have
gone from 22 percent the 20
the 12% overall expenditures in Medicare
or even cases like India where there
have been announcements around quoting
price controls for services rather to
the lavatory financial aspects are
certainly very important but there are
broader underlying issues in terms of
perceptions or misconceptions that exist
that really have impact on the value
equation part of that is really being
able to see that value or may be
perceived enlarge the value but what the
clinical laboratory is able to offer and
you can see in the figures here from
healthcare professionals where they see
that the lab is a valuable resource
that's a very small percentage compared
to what the reality should be the same
thing perspective from the executive
from is seeing little to no expectation
for the lab to provide additional value
even within the laboratories themselves
expectation to have an impact and
important KPIs is really very critical
and demonstrates a gap that exists what
that impact may be the role of Clinical
Laboratory in healthcare that has an
impact and repercussions throughout the
system it means potentially not the
using that the right standards when it
comes to selecting and using the
appropriate tests for the appropriate
patient the right time it also has
concerns about the experience from a
patient perspective or even health care
professionals that are looking to take
the the right and timely decision for
patients now and moving forward while
there is a many of the trends that we've
discussed already cut across all
different markets is to recognize that
there are some differences between the
countries and I want to present some of
those results here right now
the first graph that you see here
presents from a executive from a
clinical laboratory perspective what are
those most relevant ABR's selected from
a list of 20 across critical and
satisfaction and laboratory specific
api's
and what you see here are very critical
trends some markets like the u.s.
particularly executive-level have a
high-level alignment of what those
critical KPIs are for organizations in
the case of Japan
the low percentage is particularly for
in hospital mortality rate and lab
critical result communication those
percentages tend to be lower than the
global average the bigger issue here is
the difference that exists between the
perception of what is a relevant KPI
from an executive perspective and from a
laboratory perspective even the case the
u.s. 20 percentage point difference
between his in hospital mortality rate
fall in the case of a patient
satisfaction that you have less of half
arrived directors consider that to be
critical KPI for the organization
overall at the same time there is great
concern in terms of the utilization of
testing that exists and the figures that
you see here represent from a patient
perspective so the percentage of testing
that's occurring today that is perceived
to be unnecessary now the trend across
geographies is the logical trend but
those in emerging markets that have
shifted health care systems to focus on
access and now moving towards value of a
higher level of that perceive a
necessary laboratory testing at the same
time within the box my healthcare
professional perspective and from others
lab perspective words of 24 to 28
percent of the global level receive
testing to be unnecessary and this is an
important fact as we move forward
because it's those perceptions that
certainly have an impact on behavior now
two very critical things I think we'd
all would agree upon KP of management
data analytics you start to see some of
those underlying issues impact around
perception on the KPI management side as
I mentioned before executives believe
the laboratories to be one of those plot
functions in achieving
the goals of the organization but how
that how can that be the case but lab
director is less than half right
actually actually have a direct
involvement in setting those KPIs what
that generates is a misalignment what
goals of organization shares in this
case you can see labs and executives
share only two of the top five patient
satisfaction and number of
hospital-acquired infections as KPIs
more importantly within each of their
their segments it's very clear that the
laboratories themselves have a wide
range of polls that only 54% agree in
the top five prioritized State Quarter
KPIs
they're shooting for this for a
different set of goals really has an
impact on the overall role of Clinical
Laboratory in healthcare today from a
data linen analytics perspective it is
no surprise to see the expectations from
executives to increase abilities in
areas related to precision medicine as
an example but those beliefs don't
necessarily match up both with the state
of data skills within teams healthcare
professionals in laboratory certain
directors present a very low percentage
and and their own skill set that the
ground data additionally even if there's
a belief in increasing the abilities
around data analytics the funding is not
necessarily aligned to fulfill those
needs and so that difference between the
perceptions the beliefs and the actions
create a lot of issues mom in terms of
Mis expectations when it comes to the
role in the collaboratory
even in the media future now as I
mentioned before the perceptions around
the globe aren't necessarily the same
and the experience can be what's
interesting is when you break out the
experience flow data analytics you see
in the cases particularly in the UK in
this graph there's a high level of
expectation understanding from
executives and
capabilities and data analytics but the
reality for labs bomb and healthcare
professionals is those skillsets don't
match up with the expectations of sex
and to see differences of margaret's
even an emerging market like China well
there is a little bit more alignment and
what that true reality were that the
skills are at um maybe reflects whether
more capacity understand sophistication
for data analytics the greater the gap
is at the same time we mentioned before
the involvement in KPI setting what you
see here is that perceived lab
involvement in KPI exciting from the
laboratory perspectives or from the
executives and you see a quite different
on the market all difference in Brazil
over 40 percent or 93% executives
believe the laboratories involved in KPI
setting whereas just half from a
laboratory and directors Survey feel
like they're actually involved in that
process and that Delta cusp Ross all of
the markets except for the case in the
u.s. actually laboratory she like
they're more involved in KPI setting
what that leads to is a misperception is
what is the true level of integration
into critical care and the impact and
KPIs and the data points you see in the
left and the right demonstrate the
expectation of executive 77 percent of
surveyed in Brazil believe that the labs
integrated has impact a number of
hospital-acquired infections but only
14% of lab directors have that shared
belief and it's a cap that's actually
very critical now that we've seen the
state of the laboratory it's important
to take their perspective of what could
be the future role the clinical
laboratory in the future and it's
hopeful to come back to the same
framework around value based healthcare
that we introduced earlier in this
webinar from one perspective it's very
clear that the laboratory has a
tremendous amount of data and insight
and expertise that can really help drive
value and diagnosis is going to become
much more critical as the complexity of
care increases over time there's
multiple areas in which that laboratory
employer role and the value-based
healthcare equation in the right hand
side you see a number of different
examples and drive and early diagnosis
to be able to interpret and communicate
experts insights and also be able to
predict what may be a population health
needs and what is the right type of
intervention that drives value both for
the patient as well as for the system
now the good news from our research as
we frame but within this value-based
healthcare perspective is we saw a great
enabling environment of stakeholders
that want to be able to leverage the
value an insight that the laboratory can
bring to the fold on one hand from an
education perspective but there's a
greater willingness from both patients
as both healthcare professionals to
leverage proactively laboratory
recommendations on what tests to utilize
and guidance and trying to understand
what those results are and that's very
critical and demonstrates the role the
laboratory can play in bridging this
path which is clearly a trend that's
going to occur for both patients as well
as healthcare professionals at a time
when patients 40 percent of those
surveyed went out and conducted tests
around general well-being without the
connotation of a doctor on 29 percent in
cancer markers patients themselves are
going out there and looking for
information and need that in citing to
be able to understand the results and
the same thing happens for healthcare
professionals we'll talk more in detail
a little bit around the measurement of
outcomes across the data aspect is very
critical as you can see the percentage
here the stakeholders really believe
that Clinical Laboratory is the right
entity in the right function to help
drive and become a repository
when it comes to data from an integrated
and patient focused care
again you see a trend and where that
bridge as I mentioned before for the
naval in context between patients that
are very active in managing their health
and healthcare professionals are trying
to understand the myriad of new
interventions the technology that are
coming into the marketplace and trying
to figure out what are the best for
their patients I mean you're really
trying to see new models in which this
is developed and communicate in a way
that's timely and effective and
certainly outcomes and driving towards
the same set of goals is really very
critical they're trying to see that
alignment when it comes to kpi's I mean
really developing the laboratory is that
repository for for information now as I
mentioned before the data analytics
aspect is one of those starting points
because if 70 percent of data that's
generated comes to the pathology side
that really impacts the system bating
that how can we enable that that data
certainly it can be a bridge between
stakeholders I mentioned before between
patients between providers and
healthcare professionals and even heirs
who are looking to find the evidence to
be able to support one intervention over
another demonstrate that that provides
value for a certain patient group versus
others that do not you can see through
the graph the expectation that
executives have in the future
till a management or predictive
analytics on the lab playing increasing
role within the space and it really
prompts supped on the lab in a way that
can enable not just that data but also
that insight in a way that's
communicated and you see loads of
examples exist around the world from the
Atlas of variation in the UK to
countries like Vietnam are really using
aggregate data to be able to predict and
in this case to find patterns by
patients either in the future and so
models exist already today that paint a
roadmap of what could be the future the
Clinical Laboratory
the research really concludes for clear
calls to action and those call to action
certainly starts with creating that link
between the lands and outcomes by
standardizing and measuring those
intermediate KPIs how do you link the
KPIs that the labs feel like the initial
link that back to the broader KPI is
like patient satisfaction and those the
related clinical side that organizations
focus on a is certainly a very critical
aspect and sharing real-time information
making sure that's patient population
specifics and generating new mom that
are able to drive better decision-making
for all those involved lack of standards
and education is a critical aspect the
peon as we mentioned before is a
complexity of care of the advances in
medical science and in computation power
allow healthcare to take better
decisions mom you've the overwhelming
amount of information about new
learnings that needs to be disseminated
in a way that's effective for everybody
involved and that integration of all
stakeholders as I mentioned before a
participation and KBI setting tracking
those goals so there's a shared common
set of purpose that stakeholders share
and be able to drive towards the last
point that I would mention here we need
to continue to evolve a definition of
value that value isn't just related or
related specifically to healthcare for
instance in the case of Japan the
introduction of diabetes testing as a
standard of care was found to have a
positive economic impact
$2,400 pre-operation in save port city
and so expanding that value-based
healthcare definition not just a look at
outcomes and cost within a health but
also look in the socio-economic impact
is very critical to understand the value
of specific interventions for overall
society so as a conclusion
as I mentioned before one of the key
three themes it's very clear that they
are to pass it could be taken one where
is a men's opportunity to leverage the
full capability of the other clinical
laboratory and drive a better flow a
two-way flow a multi flow of information
that takes better decisions in a way
that impacts both patients as well as
health systems or if the status quo is
maintained then changes will or time 44
percent of executives surveyed believed
they could outsource laboratory function
in the future 51 percent of their
professionals believe they'd like to
have a choice of laboratory in the
future more than half of patients
demonstrate a willingness to pay for
additional amount the point is the
system's needs the patient's needs or
going to drive change and other
laboratories and those involved in all
stagers involved could be part of the
equation or change will be imposed
simply by need for the sustainability of
else's future with that said thank you
for everybody's time and I'm happy to
take questions at this moment thank you
David for your informative presentation
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the answer question box located
on the far left your screen blonde
serves many of your questions as we have
time for know let's get a start error
our first question is what was the most
surprising result from the research I
think the most surprising result is the
differences between the behaviors
perceptions and overall actions that
exist on define in one hand an
environment that really wants to enable
the clinical laboratory and leverage all
is stated insight really from a behavior
on the day-to-day interaction healthcare
professionals have or laboratories as an
example
really demonstrate that their gap
between those set of beliefs and actions
and so that was really surprising for us
to be able to say our next question
where any significance is found between
countries and current dynamics for labs
so on one hand you would expect to see a
difference in behavior in systems
between those emerging markets that face
different healthcare challenges in a
different stage is so clear social
economic development and so there was
one graph earlier on that presented a
higher level of unnecessary testing
having in markets or perceived a happy
new markets like Indonesia in China and
Brazil that is to be expected with those
systems haven't driven as much
efficiency from a cost mom perspective
as you would have in other markets
around the world but it's actually very
interesting to see the similarities even
across different types of health systems
on the dangers and the issues that are
facing the UK versus the u.s. versus
other markets like Japan um
actually face a lot of similar issues a
lack of alignment in terms of kpi
managed by the lack of data collection
the perception around healthcare
professionals and so the similarities
actually quite surprising across
geographies despite all the different
differences that exist between those
markets so David what were that views of
stakeholders around the trend towards
outsourcing the lab function again it's
interesting that on one hand the
stakeholders recognized the importance
of integrating the laboratory is part of
the overall healthcare ecosystem at the
same time executives and healthcare
professionals and patients also want to
have choice I think part of that choice
is a frustration with the system that
simply isn't giving the information in a
way that's timely impactful and really
generates a lot of confidence
particularly formations and other
stakeholders involved but there's a
clear recognition that the outsourcing
mechanism actually continues to dry of
that siloed secondary position
as a cost center of the laboratory and
not really enable all the valuable data
inside the laboratory can play within
the healthcare ecosystem do models of
success exist for the excuse me for the
clinical laboratory and what can be
learned from them and there are
wonderful models and there were a few in
the presentation the hatless of
variation the cases in vietnam and even
for still and there's pockets of these
initiatives and the study really gets
into some of those cases in detail but
all those cases are pilot in Asia
smaller initiatives that are occurring
trying to solve one element of the
bigger picture and so some of those
models exist um I do think a bigger
model of how do you generate a greater
financial flow to an area that provides
a lot of value but can't can do that in
a case where it only generates five
percent it's a little health care
spending that's not sustainable but I
think that business model is the one
where you need to see new successes in
the future we are getting so many good
questions and surveys so I think we have
time for a couple more what is the
single most important step all
stakeholders can take to leverage the
labs flow control well there's a lot of
steps that can be taken from a beginning
level to be simply than engage and have
stakeholder be involved in setting KPIs
and having transparency mission those
can't be honest but I do think there's a
bigger picture of trying to generate the
evidence of what is the real value of a
different type of test and how that
information really impacts that how
comes that matter for organizations is a
very clear that particularly executives
understand patient satisfaction and
hospitality mortality rates infections
are great measures to be able to see are
you driving value or not for the system
how can you link that back to the work
that the clinical laboratory does on
presenting that evidence
and a way to spur futile and it really
defies decisions bomb and
decision-making particularly when
choosing the different types of tests
and who should be in the position to
defining which tests should be used
based on the patient needing the
characteristics that we have I think
that's an area in which stakeholders
think together and really Drive that
evidence in a way that's dynamic is over
time we're going to learn more and what
works well what doesn't and it looks
like we have time for one more question
for those in labs today what is the key
action point stemming from the research
well there's two messages for for the
lab a the status quo and the model of
the curse today is not sustainable
certainly all the efficiencies that have
been generated for the clinical
laboratory everybody within the
healthcare ecosystem benefit from that
but that cost driven model is certainly
not sustainable it's not sustainable for
the overall healthcare system and so I
think the real key message is to make
sure that you're part of that broader
healthcare ecosystem um an understanding
what are those KPIs and simply saying we
have a role to play other than just
process it processing tests and doing
that in a way that's efficient that's
certainly very important but the more
important thing is helping drive better
healthcare decisions and so starting to
be involve that process simply
understanding what does KPIs and sort of
the track then being better aware of
that I think would be a good first step
for those my department
thank you David I think my only final
comment is um beyond reading the study
and get to know the research that was
done is that this is a really critical
element and one that's not talked about
and which has become a bit of a catch
phrase in value-based healthcare um but
the clinical laboratory holds all of
this information that can be leveraged
in a way that's powerful impactful for
all systems and patients alike
then we need to figure out a way to
enable both these systems as well as the
individuals and the knowledge that
exists within the clinical laboratory
because it's the insights the data is
one aspect but the insights are as poor
as everything else and so putting in a
more enable all I think it's very
critical for all is involved and we
can't achieve the healthcare that we
want without the laboratory playing a
critical space
thank you again David for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank laberd's our
sponsor Abbott for underwriting two
things that educational web cameras
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today and they'll
submitted during the on-demand period
it'll be addressed by the speaker you
know the contact information you
provided at time of the registries this
webcast will be available on demand or
8ball a 2019 lab routes will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event you'll now be
redirected to the Abbott website where
you can download the whitepaper until
next time goodbye